mon attaque réussie proto julien hydro
sera fonctionnel si les bouddhistes ont
atteint 1 9 tonne minarro dire qu'ils
étaient diffamatoires et voir où en est
qui double sa rocade il prône scénariste
de nasri karim
qui aimait jouer losc hazard de ski qui
livre d'enfant je n'y attache au grain
volodymyr zelensky le nom du président
ukrainien est absolument partout en ce
moment mais alors qui est il réellement
ce que l'on sait moins c'est que avant
d'être chef d'état ou chefs de guerre
volodymyr zelensky a été humoristes
stars de télévision acteurs de séries ou
encore chanteur de music hall un cv qui
forcément soulève beaucoup de questions
alors comment volodymyr zelensky est-il
passé d'humoriste à ennemi numéro 1 de
vladimir poutine qui est il réellement
aujourd'hui c'est donc une vidéo très
spécial ou à se plonger dans la vie très
particulière de volodymyr zelensky
l'homme qui est désormais confronté à un
moment marquant de l'histoire et au
passage avant de commencer n'hésitez pas
évidemment à vous abonner pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes ça peut être
les interviews des candidats à la
présidentielle compost en ce moment nos
reportages nos interviews et aussi
poursuivre la guerre en ukraine au
quotidien parce que forcément il se
passe beaucoup de choses qui méritent
d'être traitées je vous invite à suivre
notre chaîne youtube d actu du jour que
je vous mets en descriptions ou encore
notre compte instagram long du compte
c'est hugo décrites
[Musique]
retour donc pour commencer 44 ans en
arrière pour le dhimmi relenti est née
le 25 janvier
1978 dans une ville ouvrière au sud-est
de l'ukraine une ville qui donc à
l'époque appartient à l'urss comme
l'ukraine il naît dans une famille de
scientifiques d'origine juive et
russophone c'est après des études de
droit que vos lumières et lenski décide
de participer dans les années 90 un jeu
télévisé humoristique très populaire en
russie ce jeu c'est le cas vn et kpn
c'est en fait l'acronyme du club d être
joyeux et débrouillard le principe de ce
jeu est assez simple plusieurs équipes
représentent chacune une ville et ses
équipes s'affrontent dans ce qui
ressemble à un concours de stand-up
c'est donc là que va commencer en fait
la notoriété de zelensky il séduit
tellement dense et stand-up qu'il décide
avec deux autres membres de sa troupe de
monter leur propre boîte de production
cette boîte de prod porte le nom de
leurs troupes var talent 95 selon hélène
ce qui à l'époque l'objectif de cette
boîte de production ces jeux site de
faire du monde un endroit meilleur
un endroit plus gentils et plus joyeux à
l'aide de ces outils dont nous disposons
qui sont l'humour et la créativité leur
entreprise va donc organiser à ce moment
là des dizaines et des dizaines de
concerts mais aussi produire énormément
de chaud des shows aux hellènes ce qui
va apparaître quasiment à chaque fois au
jeune kei qui berne nationale ici et le
rwanda
leur boîte de production c'est aussi des
films
[Musique]
c'est aussi des séries télévisées en
russe et en ukrainien ou encore la
version ukrainienne de danse avec les
stars une émission à laquelle élise qui
va participer lui-même ce qui veut dire
donc il va être à la fois le producteur
mais aussi un participant il esquive en
l'occurrence remporter cette édition de
danse avec les stars
[Musique]
à cette époque donc faut bien comprendre
que zelensky est déjà bien connue mais
sa carrière va véritablement décoller et
prendre un tournant en 2015 c'est un
tournant en l'occurrence cette fois-ci
davantage politique en effet cette année
là il crée co écrit une série qui
s'appelle serviteur du peuple cette
série qui est donc une critique du
système en place à l'époque imagine la
montée en politique d'un homme bon et
droit c'est un homme bon et droit n'est
autre que vacille au le bourreau de co
et c'est un personnage joué par
volodymyr celles et ceux qui la série
fait donc un carton absolu elle finit
même par être rachetée par netflix est
aujourd'hui encore serviteur du peuple
est le plus gros succès télévisuel de
l'histoire de l'ukraine jeudi au passage
vous êtes curieux une série qui est
aussi disponible gratuitement sur arte
tv jusqu'au 18 mai la très grand succès
pour la série et c'est là que ça devient
très intéressant d'un point de vue
politique le président que zelensky joue
à l'écran est tellement populaire que
les instituts de sondages commencent
même à tester l'hypothèse d'une
candidature est une candidature donc de
zelensky et cette fois ci dans la vraie
vie
la politique c'est pas du cinéma c'est
la vie réelle
je veux vraiment aider l'ukraine
en 2008 le soir du réveillon la fiction
devient réalité en quelque sorte puisque
volodymyr zelensky annonce sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
avec un parti qui porte le nom de sa
série serviteur du peuple il ya eto'o
une déclaration qui se fait alors qu'au
même moment les chaînes de télévision
retransmettent les voeux présidentiels
de petro porochenko le président de
l'époque à ce moment-là zelensky
l'humoriste devient donc et zelensky
candidat mais pas n'importe quel
candidat zielinski ne fait rien comme
tout le monde et sa campagne et ce que
l'on peut qualifier de minimaliste il
n'organise aucun meeting électoral et ne
participe plus largement à aucun
entretien télévisé sérieux
j'ai suffisamment de force et d'énergie
un widget yahoo bien sûr que je n'ai pas
toutes les connaissances qu'il faut pour
être un homme politique mais je suis en
train d'apprendre zelensky préfère en
fait faire campagne sur scène lors de ce
spectacle car oui zelensky va continuer
de se produire ont tourné avec sa troupe
d'humoristes jusqu'à l'élection il
communique aussi énormément sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ne dévoile aucun
détail au quasiment aucun détail
concernant son programme politique et au
reaching en valeur l'image comme il ya
deux ans à bichat n'y est pas tant
pis vining tout au long de sa campagne
d'hélène ce qui va donc jouer sur
l'ambiguïté avec le personnage qu'il
incarne dans la série serviteur du
peuple en utilisant par exemple les
décors de sa série pour faire ses
allocutions cette stratégie d'ailleurs
ressemble très fortement à ce que
raphaël llorca doctorant en philosophie
du langage appelle la netflix isation de
la vie politique selon lui de plus en
plus d'hommes politiques s'inspire
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs de manière
consciente ou non des séries télévisées
pour mettre en scène leurs discours
politique l'objectif c'est de capter
l'attention en créant des surprises des
électrochocs alors que la société est de
plus en plus soumise à la pression des
réseaux sociaux des chaînes d'infos et
où donc l'information circule de plus en
plus vite raphaël your car en fait
repérer trois ingrédients qui serait
selon lui trois ingrédients d'une
campagne efficace le personnage le
rythme et l'effet de surprise la forme
du discours politique contre est donc
aujourd'hui davantage que le fond et
pour les candidats et bien mêler fiction
et réalité pourrait permettre de cacher
par exemple des faiblesses dans leurs
programmes ou encore un manque d'idées
nouvelles et ce mélange fiction réalité
est précisément au coeur de la campagne
de volume zielinski cette ambiguïté est
telle que certains ont vraiment du mal à
prendre sa candidature au sérieux et
pour vous donner une comparaison avec la
france c'est comme si l'acteur kad merad
qu'on retrouve dans la série politique
baron noir se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle face à zemmour macron
pécresse ou encore marine le pen
forcément ce serait assez particulier en
l'occurrence même si elle ne respecte
pas les codes classiques on l'a vu donc
la campagne présidentielle de zemlinsky
semble fonctionner à l'époque zelensky
bénéficient en effet de sa forte
notoriété médiatique mais aussi du rejet
des personnalités politiques
traditionnels sont alors perçu comme
corrompu et inefficace zelensky se
positionne lui comme un candidat honnête
et droit un candidat qui défend la lutte
contre la corruption et qui prône la
démocratie par ailleurs autre élément
qui joue en sa faveur et peut-être qu'on
y reviendra la zelensky n'est pas
considérée comme nationaliste
il est donc soutenue par une forte
communauté russophone notamment dans le
sud est de l'ukraine dont il est
originaire alors pourtant sans aucune
expérience politique préalable volodymyr
zelensky s'impose comme le grand favori
du scrutin et lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle il obtient 30%
des voix et devance l'ancien président
petro porochenko ya
juste le business un business et la vie
n'est que non et bizet bellini crains
pas petit chien est alors que zelensky
continuer à communiquer quasiment
exclusivement sur les réseaux sociaux et
bien les médias ukrainiens l'appel après
le premier tour à s'exprimer auprès
d'eux dans un souci démocratique il va
donc finalement participé un débat
d'entre deux tours ça s'est passé le 19
avril 2019 au stade olympique de kitchen
sink
inquiétant ratio polonais était de la
trempe de martin hellweg
équipes échangent palatine on l'attend
sportif jacques azam celle de nadine
termine et justin bieber il ya c'est
lors de ce débat d'entre deux tours que
zelensky va révéler quelques éléments de
son programme on peut citer en vrac
qu'il est favorable à la légalisation du
cannabis médical la légalisation de la
prostitution ou encore des jeux d'argent
et sur des sujets peut-être plus large
concerne davantage la population ils
s'engagent également à baisser les
impôts à privatiser certaines
entreprises ou encore à améliorer leur
niveau de vie et aussi vous l'aurez
compris à lutter de façon importante
contre la corruption concernant les
relations entre l'ukraine et la russie
zelensky soutient un cessez le feu dans
le donbass cette région donc à l'est de
l'ukraine est frontalière à la russie la
zone est alors le théâtre de conflit
entre les séparatistes pro-russes donc
des ukrainiens qui se sentent plus et
qui soutiennent la russie et la ram et
ukrainienne de l'autre côté avec parfois
des affrontements très violents et les
crimes de guerre qui ont été dénoncés
des deux côtés par de nombreuses ong
zelensky soutient aussi l'organisation
d'un référendum sur l'intégration de
l'ukraine dans l'otan
l'auto en attendant que cette alliance
militaire avec notamment et bien des
pays européens est menée par les états
unis dont on entend beaucoup parler en
ce moment dans le cadre de la guerre en
ukraine on notera au passage que le mois
d'élections présidentielles zelensky est
absolument partout y compris dans les
salles de cinéma puisque sa dernière
comédie dans laquelle il apparaît sort
dans les salles au même moment
oui si mme klein poste à radiall
conseille aux gens
pour des beats ananas
aux sphères - jouez vos le 21 avril 2019
c'est donc la consécration volodymyr
zelensky et telus à l'âge de 41 ans avec
73% des suffrages au second tour face au
président sortant pour auch enhco depuis
l'indépendance de l'ukraine jamais un
candidat à la présidentielle n'avait
atteint un tel score au second tour
zelensky réalise par ailleurs ses
meilleurs scores dans les régions
considérées comme pro-russe alors élu et
les ce qui promet deux choses majeures
mettre fin à la corruption et rétablir
la paix dans le donbass ou plus de 14000
personnes ont alors péri depuis le début
de la guerre en 2014 erding
ripping vos réunions nadine baills sa de
la torche nachi galway bill chesney
greenway ya retrouvé nasser
et anthony boys primadesk loi ni rien
hier à deauville chat et souris aux
propos de m me beauchamp riccio vie nos
mémés bocelli arena shubi mon sac
inchirah tête volodymyr zelensky va donc
jouer sur sa posture de président comme
les autres un président normal comme
dirait peut-être françois hollande il
souhaite en faire une force c'est
d'ailleurs au centre de sa stratégie de
communication puisque le 20 mai 2019 le
jour donc de son arrivée au pouvoir ils
arrivent à pied au parlement son
limousines des tchèques à tout le monde
il souhaite apparaître comme quelqu'un
de cool et refuse qu'on le traite comme
une idole il a par exemple demandé aux
fonctionnaires de ne pas accrocher des
photos de lui dans leurs bureaux alors
peut être est ce simplement de la
communication pour séduire mais toujours
est il qu'à l'époque s'appelait est par
ailleurs fait assez particulier quand on
sait la situation aujourd'hui pour faire
des économies zelensky va aller jusqu'à
annulé la parade militaire annuelle de
la fête d'indépendance au début de sa
présidence zelensky veut croire à la
paix une désescalade des tensions avec
la russie le 9 décembre 2019 poutine et
zelensky accepte ainsi d'échanger des
prisonniers et en faisant ça le
président ukrainien se met à dos une
partie de la population ukrainienne qui
redoute de le voir faire trop de
concessions face à vladimir poutine
certains craignent alors qu' il ne fasse
pas le poids face à venir poussines dans
ces négociations et ces discussions
forcément important par ailleurs tout ça
se retrouve notamment illustré par une
étude qui a été publié en février par le
centre razoumkov qui ont montré que 55 %
de la population estimait qu en cas
d'invasion et bien volodymyr zelensky ne
ferait pas un commandant en chef
efficace capable d'organiser défense de
l'ukraine face à la russie mode se
retrouver ah ouais alors bon c'est à
beaubreuil
nontronnaise nombreux aussi à
l'abondance et de la virginia
tech aux
rebonds c'est glen stania boukai
sonorités va t'il que rené girard qui
vous permet ni alors avant l'invasion à
la présidence de zelensky n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille
on l'accuse par exemple d'être pro
russes car il est issu d'une région
russophone on l'accuse aussi d'être la
marionnette du milliardaire igor colle
au whisky un oligarque très opposé à
l'ancien président porochenko en fait
selon les opposants à zelensky co l'oms
qui lui a offert une couverture très
favorable sur sa chaîne de télévision en
pleine période présidentielle autre
accusation cette fois-ci financière
quelques jours avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle un site
d'investigation indépendant avait révélé
que céline ce qu'ils n'avaient pas
déclaré au fisc sa villa de 15 pièces
estimées à 4 millions d'euros en toscane
et trois ans plus tard donc beaucoup
plus récemment en 2021 des journalistes
ont révélé que la fortune des landes ce
qui avait été investi dans des sociétés
basées à moscou est gérée via des
compagnies offshore à chypre alors
forcément ces deux accusations majeur de
fraude qui vont à l'encontre de l'image
d'un homme politique
et droit que zelensky voulait incarner
ont terni fortement son image d'autant
plus que zelensky a toujours axé sa
campagne sur la lutte contre la
corruption et sur la classe politique
ukrainienne et en conséquence en 2021 sa
cote de popularité va s'effondrer est
passé à 23 % même s'il reste tout de
même à ce moment là l'homme politique le
plus populaire du pays d'ailleurs selon
certains de ses anciens collaborateurs
ses critiques aurait ébranlé en quelque
sorte la confiance de zelensky se serait
alors enfermé dans une sorte de bulle et
une bulle avec bien des personnes plus
loyale que compétente dans le domaine de
la politique et selon le site
d'investigation ukrainien by us le
gouvernement ukrainien comporte plus
d'une trentaine de personnes liées à sa
famille ou alors à la société qui
produisait sa série
[Musique]
terminée yat-il nombreuses myeurop dean
et actes ils n'ont eu droit de cité
green a politician
initiation of jobs alors cette vidéo
date du 25 février 2022 la veille
l'armée russe a lancé l'invasion de
l'ukraine après l annonce par le
président russe vladimir poutine du
lancement d'une opération militaire
spéciale c'est le début d'une guerre
avec à la tête de l'ukraine un chef de
guerre volodymyr zelensky le 26 février
les états unis insistent auprès de
zemlinsky pour qu'ils se replient vers
un site plus sur cultive la capitale
donc où il se trouve mais le président
ukrainien refusé cette offre et tient à
rester aux côtés de sept rouges et
d'autres affiches m
nacho de jacques boudet d'aller soit
bonne machine la crise n'est comme cela
one nation séquestration la communauté
internationale salue alors son courage
le président des états unis joe biden
déclare qu'il inspire le monde tandis
que emmanuel macron déclare qu'il
incarne je cite le visage de l'honneur
de la liberté et de la bravoure
[Musique]
fake ou une formation via ses bobcats
sont armés et des vocaux à ce match et à
ya tout l'un des espaces du conflit se
trouve sur les réseaux sociaux et
volodymyr zelensky l'a bien compris
depuis le début zelensky documente le
conflit en temps réel en se filmant en
mode selphy dans de courtes vidéos
généralement de moins d'une minute son
objectif eu le très clair donner l'image
d'un président en actions authentique et
contrer la communication et la
propagande de la russie cette
communication très horizontale on
pourrait dire du président ukrainien sur
les réseaux sociaux est à l'opposé en
fait de la communication très verticale
de la lumière poutine qui s'adresse aux
russes depuis la salle de presse du
kremlin dans des discours télévisé très
solennelle et ses discours sont
enregistrés longtemps en avance
contrairement à zelensky qui lui est
bien communiquent davantage en temps
réel et si céline ce qui apparaît dans
cette vidéo au milieu de ses
collaborateurs et bien les conseillers
de poutine eux sont tenus à distance
cette proximité où cette distance
physique est forcément assez symbolique
l'autre grande différence entre vladimir
poutine et zielinski dans cette guerre
d'image et de communication c'est aussi
la tenue vestimentaire alors que céline
ce qui peut apparaître par exemple en
tee shirt et bien vladmir poutine à part
et lui dans un style vestimentaire
pareil beaucoup plus classique est
beaucoup plus strict en costume-cravate
tout le temps il semble donc impassible
et forcément aussi moins naturel cette
stratégie d'une communication très
horizontale adoptée par le président
ukrainien semble séduire puisque ces
interventions sont encore aujourd'hui
reprises par des centaines de milliers
d'utilisateurs occidentaux d'instagram
ou encore de type toc est déclinée
parfois en même pro ukraine des mêmes
qui aujourd'hui peuvent avoir un impact
politique on avait parlé d'ailleurs dans
mon émission machel je vous mets le lien
directement en descriptions vers la
chaîne youtube vous voulez voir le débat
et la discussion sur tout ça mais tout
cela pour dire donc que ça a un impact
politique majeur d'un point de vue de la
communication par ailleurs l'autre média
massivement utilisé par zelensky c'est
twitter depuis du conflit le président
ukrainien tweet toutes les deux trois
heures environ chaque tweet génère
environ entre 40000 et 400000 like l'une
de ces stratégies d'ailleurs sur twitter
c'est d'affirmer le soutien de chacun de
ces pays occidentaux l'objectif en fait
si les multiples quant aux hellènes ce
qui salue par exemple la mobilisation de
la france et des menus de mac ont bien
il sait qu'un tel prix tu es une telle
déclaration faire entraîner de très
nombreux relais média en france et y
c'est donc automatiquement des liens
entre la france et l'ukraine essaha
zelensky vous pouvez le voir directement
sur son compte twitter il le fait après
chaque appel passé avec un chef d'état
étranger multipliant ainsi les échos
partout dans le monde à 44 ans donc que
volodymyr zelensky on l'a vu un parcours
très improbable et atypique encore
inconnu sur la scène internationale
jusqu'à il ya pas si longtemps il est
désormais un chef d'état et un chef de
guerre face à la deuxième puissance
militaire mondiale qui envahit en ce
moment même son pays alors au delà de
l'actualité au quotidien sur cette
guerre en ukraine et forcément les
sujets très graves qui se passe tous les
jours et qu'on évoque donc sur youtube
ou instagram régulièrement ça me
semblait assez intéressant de mieux
comprendre qui se cache derrière ce nom
volodymyr zelensky alors cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas évidemment à
vous abonner pour découvrir aussi tous
nos autres contenus que ce soit les
vidéos concernant la guerre en ukraine
j'ai aussi les interviews et les
reportages qu'on a fait ces derniers
jours et qu'on va continuer à faire dans
les prochains jours j'espère en tout cas
que cette vidéo vous aura plu je vous
mets des liens et des ressources pour en
savoir plus dans les commentaires
surtout prenez soin de vous présenter
nos proches et on se dit du coup a très
vite